Shadowgate, your next move could be your last.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe. And we are playing today what could be seen as the precursor to all current Escape the Room style experiences across the world, right?
This is kind of an Escape the Room, except for you've chosen to go in the room.
I mean, you could call it that.
I'd also just say it's a like a point and click adventure game.
Yeah, I feel like Escape the Rooms have always sort of reminded me of this format of game, but it wasn't until
you know, later in my experience of playing this game, I actually did start thinking specifically this feels like Escape the Room.
So I don't know. It's like one of those chicken and egg things like something came.
They're both kind of evoking each other.
And Sean, you're spot on.
It is absolutely a point and click adventure game.
I only noticed as I was getting like further into the game that it just became a lot more about my inventory and less about like what was going on in the actual rooms that that made me start to feel like an Escape the Room where I have to deal with the tools that I've collected less, you know, less pointing and clicking than I'm used to in these kinds of games where like, okay, it doesn't matter what you have available to you.
It's what's on the screen that you're like trying to puzzle solve based on that, not based on what you've collected so far.
Yeah, I guess there is enough of a difference between the two types, but I guess I would consider Escape the Room more a subgenre of point and click adventure.
Yeah, I guess Escape the Room, I would say is like just solely focused on like puzzle solving where this is like there's a lot of puzzle solving, but there's also just like a lot of general adventuring going on.
And there's a lot of story too, not even just like what you read in the manual and stuff like that, what we're used to in games.
There's a lot of dialogue to or exposition or narrative to read throughout the game.
And then to also look at all the objects in the room and get detailed descriptions on that stuff.
This is a very text heavy game compared to what we're used to on the system.
I think that a lot of the backstory, it's a little opaque and in some of it, like because there is definitely a text limit, it doesn't, I couldn't entirely get what all of the, like the circle of 12 and the something of seven, like I didn't really get what all that was.
But you're right, I mean there is a lot of that.
Yeah, I also think that it being text based primarily, I mean obviously there's images too, but it's just normally stills with like very few animations and stuff.
Kind of, while like the text is obviously limited, it kind of helps to like remove limits in the video game sense of as far as like letting them do a lot of different things.
Because when it all boils down, all they have to do is text.
Yeah. Like in that kind of, I think, whether artificially or not, like I think it makes, at least while I'm playing it, it makes me be able to kind of like immerse myself and like kind of make it, it feels like a much more robust game than other like games in this like fantasy genre.
Just because like, it's almost like reading a book.
Yeah, and I think that becomes the whole like appeal of Shadowgate 30 years later, right?
What I'm saying is that in other fantasy genre games, you know, you could use like Final Fantasy as an example here.
You control this group of characters on their epic adventure and you directly interact as that character in the overworld doing these things, saying I, you know, like attacking and being tactical.
In this game, you are a character and you are exploring this, you know, castle throughout first person view.
But the way you interact with this kind of video game is way different than, you know, it's gonna sound silly, but like any of the platformers we've played or anything else.
Like you're not, you just have like the shield on you and provided that you have the shield equipped, the game does all the work for you.
There's no like, okay, now we're switching to a combat mode where you fight the dragon, right?
It doesn't, the game never takes that way.
So in that way, Joe, I totally understand what you're saying, where it does become more of a book where you're collecting these things or choosing.
It's like a choose your own adventure book.
You're choosing to perform an action and then based on where you are, what you have, what you've done, the game kind of like reads the following paragraph to you.
And then you choose the next part of the adventure based off of that information.
Yeah, you're not like, you don't have skills in this game.
Like you don't, if you, in the game, you are like an adventurer night guy.
So it assumes that if you have the correct equipment, you're probably going to do pretty well.
Otherwise, it would be kind of weird and pointless.
Right. If it relied on reflexes or fast input from the players at any point, that could get a little weird because of the way that the game works.
So I feel like before we get any further, similar to what Sean and I did in our Nostalgia Bites episode, the Portopia serial murder case, we should explain or, you know, just talk a little bit about all the different things that you're allowed to do in this game.
And as a brief overview of that, you're allowed to move where you select in a little mini map.
It shows you open areas via square boxes, and then you can click on those square boxes.
Or if you see said door on the actual screen, you can also move into those.
You can look, which allows you to get a better description of specific things in the room.
So you might be able to tell it's a sword.
But if you look at the sword, it would give you a more detailed explanation of what that sword could possibly be used for later on in the game.
Or it could be a very, very vague hint that you wouldn't be able to understand without the accompanying strategy guide.
There's the use function, which allows you to use an item, usually a combination where you select the item first and then what you want to use it on or use it on yourself.
There's open and close, which is as straightforward as it sounds.
You can open up a door or a chest or anything else that you think could open and then close it as well if need be.
You can take anything that you can see and you can hit anything that you want.
Not saying that it will actually let you take those things or that hitting those things will do anything, but the option is available to every single object in the game.
You can speak by talking out.
You can control yourself by the self option, which allows you to use items on yourself or do things in the room with yourself.
And then additional things you can save.
You can move between the inventory and you can see all your goods.
Those last three are really more of like inventory and game management things, not necessarily related to the actual world of Shadowgate.
But I think now that we've laid out those moves, that's kind of that shows, I think, how many permutations in any given room of things that you have available to you.
And what makes this game so broad and branching from the player's standpoint is that every single room you enter, you could just try to brute force your way into another room or into collecting everything in the room.
But that's not the best way to play Shadowgate.
And you kind of need to understand everything you can do here and then use those tools to explore said room.
Yeah, and that being said, I feel like they do a really good job of because you're thrown into this game with all of these options.
And it's almost a little overwhelming at first because you're just like all these things you can do.
And I think there's just some really good game design in just the first couple of rooms that that gives you that teaches you what to do and when to do it.
And like the kind of things you should look out for in this game, like in the very first two rooms, you know, you get to the second room.
There's already a dead end. There's a locked door without a key.
And outside of it, you have a door that you would have presumably already used the open command on.
And if you start looking at things, you'll find like there's there's a skull, a little skull above the door that says like, oh, this really makes you think that like that like danger lurks inside or something.
It uses the word lurks inside, making you think like, you know, there's nothing else you can do here.
So you might just start trying to like use the open command on the on the skull, maybe because it said something lurks inside when you clicked on the skull, too.
So it's like giving you that like a little bit of a little bit of a like a lob ball of a puzzle just so you can like understand like, oh, OK, not everything is necessarily exactly as it seems.
And I should try things.
And then following that, you go into the next room and right away, there's a book that you're just like, I'm going to take this book and you take the book and you die.
Like most people, I assume, just like they see a book and like, I'll take it, see what it is.
But if you would, if you examine it first, it kind of gives you this like idea, like maybe I should be careful, you know, so like it kind of gives you the idea, like examine things.
They'll give you hints and like try different things like that you wouldn't expect.
Right off the bat, you kind of know, like that's the kind of game you're looking for.
It's not going to be necessarily like telegraph for you.
You're going to have to figure things out.
Yeah. And stepping back a bit, just to talk about the actions that you can take, it is a very wide like palette of interactability when it comes to like what you can, how you're interacting with the world, what options you have.
Um, and going back to like comparison to that, to Portopia, uh, which was a lot more focused on like mystery solving and the things that you could do were very much about solving, uh, murder cases.
Uh, this one is much more just like, what can you tactic or tactilely with your hands do, uh, in the space provided?
Uh, but going off of Joe's point, yes, I think that those are really cool, uh, tutorials in, in those first couple areas.
I, for one, I felt really dumb.
Uh, I actually did have to open up the guide immediately because I couldn't understand that opening a skull was a thing.
Um, and, uh, but I definitely died when I took the book.
Like, so that, that taught me that anything could be a trap and I should be wary of these things.
Uh, but the skull thing was more of a, like, well, okay, this game is starting me off on the wrong foot because it's immediately going to, to something kind of out there.
I thought maybe it could, could have started with something a little bit more, a little less, um, lateral, lateral thinking and more so just like, okay, this is how you interact with something.
Yeah. I, I think it's because, uh, in Legend of Zelda, right, the tutorial there is to enter that cave that is very clearly seen to the person.
You can go walk off without a sword and try to get as far as you can and you'll have nothing to fight back with, but you enter the cave and then you get the sword.
That's, that's somewhat of, of a very beginning tutorial.
There's the Super Mario Brothers World 1-1 where obviously we've talked about it at length in that episode, but it teaches you the idea of jumping over pitfalls.
This game probably has to be a little more difficult just to, you know, set up the idea of what you're, how you're going to be solving puzzles in this game.
It's not like the world's hardest puzzle or anything.
Uh, I think Joe saying that, you know, by using the look function, it would give you a little more detail about that skull and you'd be able to theoretically solve it on your own.
I'm not saying you're dumb, Sean.
I didn't solve it either.
Uh, but it's not like, it's not the world's worst tutorial either.
It's not like they purposely made it hard, but yes, they totally could have had something that was more chest-like that you then had to open to find the key that you needed.
And then you understand like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I got to open things to get items.
I got to take said item and then I have to use it on the door in the same room.
This one's a little interesting because you actually have to like exit back out of the castle and go use the only other thing in your surroundings.
Uh, but I, I do think it's a great puzzle now that I've played most of Shadowgate.
Like I do think it has a great way of explaining to you that this game is going to have some, uh, really, uh, little hidden trinkets all around that you're going to have to kind of explore the pixel art and say like, hmm, maybe this isn't just on the wall.
And maybe this is something that I need to interact with.
You know, we've seen that a few times in this game, even bricks.
It's like, hmm, that brick is slightly off colored.
I should hit it.
You know, you can definitely tell that like this game, it, it, it lends itself well to sort of like playing as a team with like, Ooh, why don't you try using that on that?
Or like, well, that thing looks weird.
Let's, why don't you try doing that?
Um, but the game definitely expects you to get stuck a lot because I feel like the only way that somebody would decide to try and open a slightly brighter brick than something else is if they've literally tried every other option.
Well, I'll say too, that I, I may have been, um, been a little generous when I said like, Oh, the hint of like something lurks inside, uh, is a great hint.
I mean, you know, maybe that that's still kind of a tough hint.
I guess I kind of like lucked into this, but, but like, I just went into the second room.
There was no key there. I went back out and I just started trying things and I was like, well, there's only a few things on the screen, so I'll try this skull.
I did try to take the skull, but that wasn't it.
Yeah. Cause I feel like if you just imagine a world where the guide is not that accessible to us, I feel like just with time, like there's only so many things you could try.
And so like, it's not that that puzzle in itself is not like a game breakingly frustrating puzzle where like, if you just didn't have the option to, to look at the manual, you probably would have found it eventually just by trial and error.
And then that kind of shows you two things that like things aren't always as they seem.
And like the solution to the problem you're having is not always in the same room.
You might have to go back and remember something else.
Like, I just feel like that sets up that for the game.
And an important thing here too, when we're talking about looking at guides or stuff like that, it's, this game is not a game that you can play with a guide.
You're not playing it then at that point, especially because there's no inputs to be done really.
That feels like you're just, you know, watching a YouTube video at that point.
It feels weird doing everything in the order exactly as intended.
This game is at its best when you have the, you know, as they reference it in the manual, the Shadowgate hint guide book, which you could have ordered for $5.99 back in the day.
If that had come in the mail, which is what I wound up using for my playthrough, that just gives you hints in three different layers of difficulty.
It has an A tier, a B tier, and a C for each kind of puzzle in the game.
So first you figure out. And C is just telling you where it is, right?
Right. C gives you the answer outright.
B is a little more suggestive.
And A is so vague.
It's like sometimes I just go right to B.
I'm like, okay, well, what the hell does that mean?
Do these correspond to the in-game hints?
No. No, they don't.
It's more like there's a layout of very specific spots where you will get stuck in the game.
And you look at that specific thing that you're stuck in.
And it has a line in it for like, you know, what you're trying to do.
And it says, go to A32, B47, or C6.
You know, so then you go to the index.
First, you try the A thing.
See if you can solve it based off of that.
If you still can't figure it out, you go to the B.
And if you still can't figure it out, ideally, you would then go on to the C, which would tell you the answer outright.
That's the creative way to still like get a solving mechanic that doesn't revolve around using a strategy guide for this game.
Because when you use a strategy guide, I don't know, the whole point of the game, right, is that you're going to die.
They come up with so many kinds of creative deaths and weird deaths and things that you wouldn't think could kill you, do kill you.
The point of the game is to explore and just kind of, you know, try to take every single thing in the game or open everything you see.
Because you're always just, when you die, you're just going to start back on the previous screen, right?
So it's not like experimentation is frowned upon.
Using a strategy guide was something that right away just didn't sit right with me.
Yeah, I agree.
I feel like it's like if you were to compare it to like Super Mario Brothers and you're playing that and you're stuck in that endless dungeon and you just don't care about this puzzle because you just want to go stomp on some Goombas or whatever.
Maybe you'd use a guide so you can get back to like the gameplay element that you like.
This game, the gameplay element is figuring out where to go next.
So if you look up where to go next for everything, you're not doing the thing that is supposed to be the challenge.
But I'm also, I'm not going to frown upon somebody that like has been trying to get past this one thing forever.
And they've been playing normally up until then.
And they just, you know, they just need to get past it so that they can enjoy figuring out other things.
Yeah, and I won't pretend that I didn't use a guide at all either.
I did a couple times towards the end.
Only though, I'd say because, well, one, because I wanted to finish the game before we recorded this.
And two, because I've just been burned by NES games before in the sense where it's like, well, this, you would absolutely never figure this out without a guide.
So I'm like, well, if that's, what if that's happening right now and I'm just wasting my time and I need a guide.
And then I would look and sometimes I would think that that's the case.
And then maybe like later on, I would realize like, oh, you know what, there kind of was a hint.
And if I had unlimited time, maybe eventually I would have figured this out.
But like some of them are pretty, you know, pretty vague.
So I like, I think they're all possible, but some of them would take you a long time.
Well, I had an experience like that earlyish on in the game where I got to the room with the tombs in it.
There's like three tombs on each side and they're closed or whatever.
So I just started opening them from left to right.
And I opened the middle one on the left and green slime oozed out.
And it blocked me from exploring the rest of the tomb because no matter what I did, I would walk on that slime and it would be like, you just got slimed.
And then the Grim Reaper would show up and I'm like, what?
Like that's a death?
What's in the slime?
Like, why can't I jump over it or whatever?
Anyway, not the point.
The point being that for the longest time, I assumed that I had just like, I had just gotten stuck in the game.
Obviously, you can't soft lock yourself, but I assume.
So you mean you thought that the slime needed to be poured out?
No, or that by pouring it out, I blocked myself off from those other doors.
The only other doors in the game that I thought were left at that point.
I thought I had explored everything else.
And thanks to the nostalgia discord, I just wound up throwing it out there.
I was like, you know, I'm trying to like brute force my way to exploring those other tombs.
There's a mummy in one of them that I could technically interact with.
Everything else I can't interact with.
What am I missing?
And, you know, even then I got like some polite hints about, you know, have you been to the basement?
Which is pretty suggestive, but I was like, I definitely have not been to a basement.
I wasn't told how to get to that basement, but after just going back to the other rooms and just looking through things, sure enough, I got to the basement on my own.
Like nobody told me specifically the things I had to interact with or take or whatever.
And I don't know, that's like a cool thing where, yes, every puzzle is possible and is solvable.
But sometimes you just need that reassurance or modern day functions of the Internet to just kind of lead you in the right direction and make sure that you're not completely screwed, right?
Well, if we're going to share points where we got stuck because of certain things, I want to talk about torches.
So, so there's like torches are used and it's basically to counter just trying to brute force and trying everything.
I think like there's enough, like anytime you perform an action, even like looking, moving, using, whatever, your torch loses a little bit of a little bit of itself.
Um, and once it gets low enough, you'll get some like scare tactic music and it's like, okay, I need to light another torch.
And if I don't, then I think the game's over because you're stuck in the dark and you fall over and hit your, hit your face, whatever.
So, in your inventory is torch and it shows you the number of torches you have.
And then on your inventory, it will, it has a couple torches.
You can have two torches lit simultaneously.
You can use them to stagger so that you're never like at risk of running out.
But at a certain point, you need to light certain things on fire.
There's another line item for a torch.
I learned later that it's a very special torch that has like some rings on it and it's like, uh, it's actually a weapons sort of torch.
But I just took it as, oh, this is the torch I use when I actually need to use it in the world.
Um, uh, so that I don't accidentally light another torch when I don't really need to and waste that torch.
You guys are following me right now, right?
Yes. So, there's another way to interact with the torch and it's to literally navigate your cursor to the light, to the torch that's lit.
I did not know that you could select it.
I thought it was just like a part of the HUD, an indicator.
But you can select a lit torch and then start the fire or melt the thing, uh, on the screen.
I just, that's just something that I don't think I was dumb in terms of puzzle solving.
I was just dumb in terms of knowing the actual user interface.
So, that I had to look up the, look up a guide for.
I got stuck at that same point too.
And I was doing the same thing. I was using that like alternate torch or whatever, the one that's not part of your other collection of torches.
Uh, and, and I was using it in a couple of things.
And then it wasn't until I went somewhere else that I didn't even know I needed to use a torch.
And I found out, uh, eventually that, that there are these in-game hints.
If you hit start, it gives you a hint in a lot, in like a lot of the room.
Which is exclusive to the NES version.
Sorry to cut you off too.
Oh, is it? I just thought that that was, that's a really cool, helpful thing for a game that had been out for a while.
They probably decided like, hey, we should probably include this because the NES audience is younger than the computer audience.
Yeah. Right. And I imagine they probably also saw like the things that were like, okay, maybe this isn't like so intuitive to solve.
So, maybe a hint would be warranted here.
But at one point it said like, hey, don't forget you can set things on fire.
It said something like that.
And I was like, yeah, but I've been trying that.
And that's what just like made me like, it did make for a really cool, like the witness style moment where I was like, oh my God.
Like, could it be?
And then when it worked, like it was like, oh, that's really cool.
It worked that way. So, you came to that conclusion by yourself.
I came to that conclusion with the game's hint.
I mean, because it kept telling me something needs to be set on fire and my torch wasn't setting anything on fire.
So, like, I guess then I was like, well, there's that one that's on fire.
But, like, I don't know.
I feel like it's giving me a little too much credit because it is like, it was just telling me you have to set something on fire.
And I tried everything else that could set it on fire.
And then finally I was like, okay, well, that's there.
Maybe I can select that.
Now, Joe, do you feel like that kind of hint, though, is that that's a good puzzle?
Like, the game kind of had to go out of its way to give you an additional hint for something that wasn't really story slash adventure slash castle driven.
It was something that, like, the game handed over to you because they probably didn't communicate well enough how to defeat the Wraith otherwise.
Yeah. Like, what should it?
Well, so this this at this point that I'm talking about is the mummy.
Oh, OK. That comes out.
And like, yeah, I think I totally agree.
I think like something an alternative that should have happened should have been like, you know, the text should have said, like, the mummy comes out and it and it smells like gasoline or something like that.
Like just something that makes you think, oh, I wonder if it's going to start on fire if I let it on fire or like its wraps are so dry that they, you know, better keep it.
I don't know. Like, that's almost too obvious also.
But like some some contextual thing that like maybe there's a burnt mummy next to him or something.
Right. Just like then there's a contextual clue rather than the game saying, don't forget you can set things on fire.
Yeah. Hint like that is.
Yeah. Like not the best kind of hint.
But I imagine that that was something that like they realized, oh, and the PC version, like nobody's been able to really figure this out because it's just kind of random.
So let's just toss in this like easy hint.
The castle itself is full of secrets.
Like that's the whole idea, right, is that this castle is crazy and there's all these different things that you're going to have to try to figure out how to get to rooms that don't technically exist or whatever.
That's how the king pitched it to you.
Right. Yeah. When they were building it, they were like, yeah, this is going to be like crazy.
This is going to be like the world's hardest castle to navigate.
Like that's why I'm building it like this.
And that's why it's going to have a waterfall.
But speaking of the waterfall, that's what I'm getting at is, you know, similar to the torch thing that you were talking about, Sean, where you're like, oh, I didn't think I could actually touch the torch on the UI.
Sometimes they, on purpose, don't show things on the little mini map that are areas you can go to as well because they're trying to keep them a secret.
Like going behind the waterfall to find the red blue and I think it's a white gem.
To find those three gems, you have to go behind the waterfall, but it doesn't show up on the mini map.
So therefore, you either have to notice the small little hole, select move and click into it, or you have to find out about it via, you know, some hint that isn't necessarily like given to you inside the game.
Contextually, that is.
Not contextually, yeah.
Non-contextually. Honestly, this was one of, maybe it was the first time, it was one of the first times that I used a guide because I was like, I was just lost in all these rooms.
See, because I actually got there.
I feel better about myself now.
Yeah, I feel like it just comes down to like circumstance because you can kind of see like a crack behind there.
I'm assuming that's what you noticed or like.
I noticed that there was a, there was more gap than I would have expected on the waterfall.
And I'm like, oh, maybe.
And then it worked.
So. Yeah.
See, isn't that like a really cool moment?
Yeah, it is. I like those.
I didn't think it was going to work and it worked. But it also, I do get what Mike is saying in that you've got this tool that is sort of simplifying it, making it easier to navigate so that you don't have to keep clicking around the screen.
It's just pointing to where all of the entrances and exits are, places you can go.
And yet, in just a small amount, I think it happens somewhere else where you can, I think there are other points where there are secret passageways that you have to actually manipulate the screen instead of using the nav box.
But if it's only a couple exceptions, it kind of makes you second guess that as a tool.
I don't, I don't know.
Yeah.
And I went through the map and tested out the hints.
And the hint there was, take a look at that waterfall.
Kind of looks like you could fit behind there or something like that.
Like, it was literally that.
So, like, had I known about the hint, that one would have been a really easy one, actually.
But, like, I just didn't know that it would do that.
And I guess going into a little bit more detail, unnecessarily, there are other secret passageways that you will, like, oh, you hit the book and so it opens.
And now on the little nav pad, there's another entrance that you can use.
Maybe if you just looked at that little dark crevice and then you just exclaimed to yourself, like, oh, I can get behind there.
And then it opens the entrance and that fixes the issue logically.
But, well, they didn't do that.
Yeah. And I'm less concerned about number of secret passages.
My point was actually going all the way back to the torch thing again of just how the game itself, like, the way it sets up all the things that you can do in the game and the inventory that you have.
The fact that little things like that, using the torches that are actually lit on your screen, like, not knowing that those are interactable, not knowing that there's passageways you can go behind, at least the very first time you do it.
Instead, looking at things and requiring to have to look at them several times for it to actually trigger the thing.
I'm thinking about that E-rope room or what?
E-pro. E-por.
E-por, yeah. I actually said rope backwards, but just the E part, not the whole thing.
Big Latin. Yeah.
E-por, you know, you have to, you learn the spell by looking at it three times.
And the first time it doesn't, like, suggest that anything is going to happen.
And the second time it kind of hints that, like, you know, oh, maybe you're seeing something.
And then the third time it actually teaches you the spell.
I don't know. It's just little things like that with the way that the game set itself up to work that are a little disappointing.
They're fun secrets and they feel good.
Like, Sean, you were saying you feel proud of yourself to have known that you solved the waterfall thing on your own.
That was also a joke, but yeah.
Yeah, yeah, but you know what I'm saying.
Like, to the right player, anything that requires some kind of intellect, right?
The game didn't necessarily hand it to you.
You could just go open any door in this game, right?
You're not going to feel good about, like, yeah, I opened that door and I walked right through it, right?
Like, that's not the appeal of the game.
The appeal of the game are the secrets, but I think some of the secrets or, you know,
even just a good batch of them require something that the rules of the game, especially given the limited, very limited manual explanation of, like, how to do anything in this game.
I don't know. It just doesn't feel like it's fully player friendly.
Well, on that note, I mean, okay.
There are several specific instances that we have pointed out in which the game is not fully player friendly.
But I did just want to say that, like, once you realize that, yes, there's a key in the skull and, yes, you can use the torch to light things and whatever,
the actual usability of this interface, in general, I found to be very player friendly.
Like, I know what that map is doing.
I know that you can use stuff on yourself in ways that I didn't fully understand in games like Nobunaga's Ambition, which is also a very menu and text heavy game where I was just sort of like,
I don't know, I guess I'll buy some rice.
Like, there is, and I know it's not the same thing, but there's enough feedback and the feedback is quick enough and the descriptions are clear enough and the translation good enough that I did think that this actual GUI has aged pretty well.
Yeah, I kind of felt the same way because I'll say at first, like, I noticed the age pretty quickly where I was like, okay, yeah, I have to open the door.
I have to unlock the door.
Then I have to click open.
Then I have to open the door.
Then I have to click move. Then I have to move through the door.
Then I have to select the item.
And then I have to select use. And then I have to like combine it with the, like, you know, I have to select the slingshot, but then I have to also select a stone.
And I have to use the stone on the slingshot, then use the slingshot on the enemy.
and I was like at first I was like man this is tedious
but I'll say that evaporated pretty quickly
like I just got used to it and it was like yeah
there's an extra step here and there but it did feel
pretty organic and it was like
it was never
I was never super confused minus a couple of things
where it's like yeah we didn't know that you can use those torches
and what not that felt like deliberate
like a deliberate moment to be an
aha moment so like
the interface never felt like it held it back
for me or like
or made things confusing and I think a lot of that
is because again
because it's text based so like a lot
of the things that might be confusing in another game
you use something on a door and something happens
and they're trying to rely on this like
pixelated imagery and sound
to happen like this is just
they just describe what happened
so like there's clarity
there where there aren't in a lot of other games
and whether the actual
story is good
or deep or intriguing
this is one of the
most immersive NES
games we've ever played
not just from a storytelling point of view
but from a you know video games
let you explore another world
point of view right
yeah and I think even compared to
its closest analog
Portopia Murder Mystery
I think like I was
again minus
the torch thing
I was never sort of
taken out of it
as much
as that game
there were more instances
where I'm just like okay how do I actually
how do I how do I manipulate this game
to do what I want it to do
in in there were
less in this game
than there was in Portopia
is what I'm trying to say
there are tons of items
that you find in this game
tons of weapons
that you can equip on yourself
armor
what have you
spells you can learn
to then use
my point being
we can't we can't go over
everything and I'm not asking you
to necessarily call out
favorites but what do you think
about the fact that there is
no combat system
or that there is no
um you know these things
act like checks
uh at particular moments
like oh you can't get
any further
in this room
because you don't have
this item
either equipped
or combined
with the right thing
or using it
on the right thing it's really just acting
as um
progression points
granted a little more
skillfully than we've seen
in most games but they're not
actually like you know
having the sword
doesn't require you
to then uh use the sword
on any uh enemies
I think that
like well just splitting that up
into the first part
of the question being like
there's no combat
and it's all based on these
like more cerebral things
I think that's perfect
for this game and I think a lot
of other games would have thought
we're making a video game
on the NES we need to
we need to have some action-y element
I mean think of
all the other games that have tried to do
like 3D
quote-unquote
exploring through
like a maze this accomplishes
the same thing of exploring through
a maze but it's not doing
like a 3D effect it's not making you
like run it's not making you
do any sort of attack
it's just focusing
on what the main thing
it's trying to do and I think that
that's why it feels like
so much more complete
of an experience
because like it's just playing
to that strength and not trying
to like add
other elements
of gameplay for the sake
of like making it more
video game-y because that's just
not what it's trying to be
yeah I agree
I'm you're speaking
to a guy
who's one of their
favorite games
is a game
in which you have a gun
but there is no combat system
so I think
that that was also like
using weapons
more so as tools
in an exploration
slash adventure
situation
and not so much
a twitch
like testing of skills
of video game
skills I think that
that was what this game
needed and if it
didn't do that
and it went in a like
alright and here's
the we're gonna take
you to the battle screen
and it's gonna
have some half-baked
battle system
that would have
really hurt the
game correct me if I'm
wrong but there is a
sword in this game
you don't use
that sword for anything
right or did I
forget I could have swore I used
no I used
the sword to kill
the golem
thing after I
hit him with the sling
otherwise he gets back up
oh yeah I did that too
that's right and then when you examine
him afterwards it's like
yeah it's dead what'd you think
stabbed him
with a sword a little
sense of humor I forgot
that that happened because I
was just noting that in the manual
it says like
all you need
is your wits and like and a
sword would be
helpful too and I thought
maybe that was like a little
winky joke to
the fact that you'll get the
sword and never use it
oh I also I did kill
myself with the sword once
accidentally I kill myself
just by hitting myself
I just saw
stars I thought
that you had to equip the sword
so I used the
sword on self
and they died there is a
write-up guide
on game FAQs
for just the
the deaths
and all the different ways to
die if you wished
to to know them
all it's for the
NES version but I'm sure it's not
too different from
all the other different versions
you don't have to tell me a favorite
death or anything but I do feel
like that's part
of Shadowgate's
allure right is
the fact that
you are at least
for me I was constantly creatively
dying it wasn't
always the same thing over and
over again in
fact if anything it sucks that the
torch system is the
thing that kills you the most because
you wind up running
out of your torch or whatever
that's the least creative death in my
opinion is what I
can't survive in the
dark like I'm like I got this
far but now that
the lights are out I suck I'm sure I
have enough time to to light another
torch but some of
these other ones are are just very
creative I even like
the you got slimed
one I know I was like you got slimed
I know I was pissed that like I thought I
locked myself but the
idea of being slimed
is just like I don't know that yeah that
could be gruesome or
it could be really funny well there was
no pain my favorite
way that I died was
pretty early on where
there's a trap door
and it's it leads
to the e-pore
room you can go
down and the
moment that I realized that maybe
things weren't going to go the way I
thought they were the description said
that you fall for a
few moments and
then it shows you
the room and I'm
like oh okay I'm in
the room and then
it says oh no you've
broken both your legs you're not
going to die immediately but you're
you're toast it's
gonna take a while
bye I wish I could
think of like I
know there were a couple that I was
just like come on
it's just like it's like comically over
the top like gruesome
and just like how I randomly died but I
cannot think of any
right now and I like
the descriptions though
too it's one thing to
just say like you know you died from
falling or you died
from impaling yourself
but like they really go
into detail I'm only
using this one as an example because I
haven't pulled up on the game FAQs thing
but on the lookout
point where you find
the gold pot if you
choose to take the gold pot it doesn't
just say that the
alligators ate you it
says as you move the
pot you realize that
you have fallen for
the oldest trick in the
book you suddenly find
yourself knee-deep in
the moat it seems that
the alligators really
enjoy your company like
it just you know you
picture what happens
next with you and the
alligators you know
well there was also
one that like this is
one that I was playing
with a couple friends too like you said like
where we were trying to figure things out
together and we were
all just like what like
come on where what it
was was there's that
room with the three mirrors oh yeah the
center mirror is the one where you see a
reflection and I guess that's like your hint
that like that's the one one of them
takes you to space but yeah that's the
one you you you hit
that mirror and it says behind the mirror
is a portal to the middle of outer space
you're sucked through
and like you're like
it's just like what
it's crazy it's crazy
I told you yeah it's a crazy castle when the
king does um it's not
a king though right it's
um it's a warlock lord
who you're going in
warlock lord yeah I
don't know if it's the
warlock named lord or
if it's just the warlock
ward lord and the
castle is castle
shadow gate uh that's
where the name comes
from I'm I mean you
know we don't have to get into a lore or
anything but I think
that that's funny that
uh we went the whole
thing with without
explaining why it's called shadow gate
yeah you can save in this
game but you know if
you're playing it uh
you know through emulation or whatever
uh or however you
choose to play video
games these days I
I noticed that you
know just using the
torch thing as an example again when the
torch goes out you
die and then you're
only just brought back
one previous room at
least in my experience
maybe later on in the
game it moves further
moves you further back
but that's not really
like a lot of punishment you don't
lose any of your items which which I
think is a good call
because that'd be kind
of confusing to do
inventory and see if
you can spot what
you're missing or
missing all of it that
would be crazy too having to re-explore the
whole castle uh but
because you just go back
one screen I almost
never bothered relighting
my torches before it
was too late I would
just accept the
punishment of death go
back one screen and
just have a new fully
lit torch uh to me I
didn't have to think
about an inventory system for that kind
of stuff a lot of
times in this game death is one it's
fine that it's easy
and to to come right
back because then that encourages
exploration but if
there's you know if
they're gonna have like things like oh
the torch goes out and you die it just feels
like well then what's
the punishment for
death yeah I mean I
guess it would make
it more punishing if uh
it just brought you
back to a set place
with the same amount
of torches or just
that one torch at that
torches level um so
that you'd have to go
and find one real quick
but it's a finite
resource and that
would definitely lead
you to soft locking
so I really don't know
what their other option
would be unless there
were set checkpoints
um but even then
you just you've
already solved the
puzzle so it's not
going to take you too
much longer now that
you know how to do
everything so I don't
know how you would punish the player in
this situation yeah
that's a good plan I was thinking the same
thing it was checkpoints
but but that's true if
you already know the answers you're just
making them like do
more work because adventure games yeah
in adventures games in
general like that's
that's it's kind of
it like deaths are
just the thing that
they're usually funny
um and it's just like
okay you need to you're
just going to be stuck like the fail state is
being stuck not so
much dying yeah I mean
I'm of two minds of it
because on one hand
and this is probably the
one that I that I lean
more towards I think
that it not being super
punishing is good for
this game particularly
because the game is not
about overcoming these
challenges that like you
need to try and redo or
anything it's about your
progress and like figuring
out the puzzles and like
there's nothing particularly satisfying
about like game over
redo all these puzzles
that you already know the
answer to yeah so like
I'm glad that it's not
punishing too punishing
for this game but you
know Mike you have a really good point about
like the torch thing like
that was clearly implemented to give
you like a sense of
time a sense of urgency
and it's sort of like
completely and immediately
undermined by the fact
that there's no real
punishment for letting
your torch go out other
than going back one
screen so I'm not really
sure what the alternative
is but but that also
leads me to the question isn't it possible already
to soft lock the game I
mean quote-unquote soft lock I guess just
fail if you run out of
torches and you I mean
you can just run out of torches and then you and
then when you die you go
back one screen and still
don't have enough torches
but I think you get the
fully lit torch and you
can go pretty far on a
torch so you'll die a lot
but you will know what
to do do torches respawn
like no
so like couldn't you just
run out of torches and
everywhere that I guess there's always like going
to be more torches as you
progress yeah and then
once you do progress then
that problem will probably
go away yeah
but I guess it's really
just a an annoyance
yeah on the discord
one of our discord
users told us that
there is an achievement
for the retro
achievements website which is where
you can link it to
emulated consoles and then
unlock achievements
that way yeah really cool stuff
there is an achievement
for this game
where you just use
three torches
through the entire game
and I believe
if the math is right
that is 90
moves
so it is possible
to beat this entire
game in just 90 moves
granted that doesn't
I don't think that
means 90 actions
that means
actual moving
from one screen
to another okay so maybe it is
just movement that
makes the torch go
okay that's the way I
remember the torches at least it never went
out in the middle
of an adventure
for me but maybe that's not true
maybe I'm misremembering
yeah I'm also
at the point where I'm not sure
if I'm remembering correctly but I
actually thought the opposite
I thought that there was a time
where like I did
something I searched
something or I picked something up
and then suddenly the torch ominous
music came on yeah who knows
we should know
there's no way
to know I'd like to jump
back real quick
and talk about I know we were
talking before about like items
and we weren't going to talk
about our favorite items but this is
one that's true
I necessarily was my favorite
necessarily say it was my favorite
but it's one
that stands out to me as something
that's like a good a good indicator
of like the the interesting
thought that was put into a lot
of these puzzles and that's there's
a I think it's
like an icy orb
or a frozen orb
or something that's an orb
you get early on
that is really cold
yes and in
you know
there's a spot that you've probably
already been at this point where
there's a lake
and on the other
side of the lake there's a skeleton
holding a key and in the lake
there's a shark so you can't get
to the key you can't swim
over there because the shark will eat you
and not you know
it doesn't take like the most
intuitive mind to be like
oh to make the connection like
maybe I can freeze the water
but it is kind of a cool
like connection
to make it might not
be the first thing you do but you freeze
the water the orb gets
frozen underwater
you walk across
you get the key you move on
later on there's another
point where
you're in a room where
like the the floor
is so hot you can't
even enter the room
and you're like oh
if only I still had that orb
and I think
eventually I kind of realized
that there was a way
I don't remember how I did it
I don't remember if it was a lit
torch is it a lit
torch yeah use a lit
torch so this must have been
after I found out you can
do that use a lit
torch on the ice
that melts
it for long enough for the
orb to like
come dislodged from the ice
and float up you let go
it freezes again you can pick up
the orb and reuse it
and it's like that's just
that's like something that
you would think
of if this were real life
you know it's not like
a rule or whatever
it's just like oh this is how
this is how physics works
shadow gate is real life
you know
what I mean like it's not just
like no I
appreciate that there's a
there's a puzzle here with like
these there's four puzzle elements
it's just like what would I do
in this situation
like and the whole
game's not like that but it is
cool to be like oh I thought of
it and I was able to do it
yeah that
it's sort of
in microcosm
one of the
things that I point out
in in a lot of
these episodes of just like
abilities not just
and like
not just being
key items having multiple
uses for things
and I'm usually
talking about like your
weapons
or your
just you know
abilities in like
an action game or a platformer
but in this situation
there is
there was a
spell that
you use
and then when you try and
use the spell again for some
reason or other they'll just say
like oh you don't need this
spell anymore which just makes
the spell a key item
and I know
that the
the ball
the ice sphere
is just
just a key
item you are also
using it multiple times
in different contexts
so I
really appreciated
that and I'm glad you brought
that up because I kind of forgot about it
yeah and like
you know if we're being
like honest and really
looking at it like yeah it's not like
I could have gone off the
rails and done something interesting
and unique that they didn't
intend but like
the first time
you play it it's like well
yeah they they intended
that but that doesn't
matter you know
but like
so like I
guess I'm saying that it's like it's not
exactly like I feel
like what you're often
looking for which is like
an ability
that you can use
it's the spirit of
like the moment you
need to use
yeah but like
but this
they just put more thought
into it it's not just like
it's not
just like this simple
like lock
and key mechanic
you know
it requires thought
I think it's worth
mentioning how the
game progresses
too uh
just probably
from the inventory standpoint
as well uh
you don't really
hold on to everything
forever
and uh
the game does kind
of feel like it changes
as you
uh explore
the castle
not necessarily from a
gameplay perspective
but more
from like
uh surroundings
and awareness
uh the
the beginning of the game
the the items
that you collect there and like
kind of like you know world that you're
building in your head I feel like it
changes pretty drastically
especially the
number of spells you'll
go on to learn
and the
types of encounters
you'll have it definitely
uh gets a little
crazier uh
the longer the game goes on
yeah it goes from
just like yeah
a pretty
mundane castle
where
you're just
like okay I found a
bone and I'm
picking up rocks
and oh
I got a sword
to okay
this is the
staff of
the golden
twelve and this is
the yada
yada of something
or other and it
you're definitely
stepping into a
more uh
like eldritch
place um
and there is
an escalation there so
it because there's
never a point where it's
like okay now this is
where the heat turns on
but it's
sort of a slow burn
to getting
to uh
this place is crazy
like the
construction workers said
and it becomes a
it becomes like a
a thing
where suddenly
later in the
game you have
pages and
pages of things in
your inventory so it's
not just like the
puzzles become harder just
in that sense where it's
like sometimes just by process
of elimination early on you
can be like well i have these four
items maybe one of them
works on this thing once you
have pages and pages of it like
you really have to think or else
waste a lot of your time yeah
in in just
trying things but
there is something kind of satisfying
also about like
uh a puzzle that
you're stumped on and suddenly you
realize it's an item you've had
for like hours
yeah that you
had never knew what to do
with like oh why did i pick
up this skull yeah exactly
yeah there's a
sphinx at one point that that
will just every time you talk to
it'll just ask
you a different riddle and like
the answer to the riddle which are
always pretty easy but still kind of
cool the answer to
each riddle is just like an item you
might have picked up or you might
not have so if
you didn't pick up that item like
you're not gonna get past the
sphinx this time until you go get
whatever item they're talking about
which really just
gives a reason for
all of those otherwise just junk
items if we're
using like a
like a skyrim
analogy it gives
them a reason to exist yeah is
that a known thing with sphinxes this
is off topic to
yes yeah they tell
riddles yeah
cool uh joe near
near the sphinx uh
that that woman
who's like tied up
too that was an interesting uh
gameplay moment for
me we have to uh
stab her with a
silver arrow to
reveal that she is
a wolf uh and
the wolf kind of looks like an
unintimidated dog
too so it's like oh i guess it
really wasn't like this really wasn't
that bad yeah
like did i really need to kill this
thing too but obviously if you
didn't do anything to it it would
have attacked you and you would
have been tricked so you have to
do that moment yep yeah exactly
don't trust the
women uh but
here we are but
i don't i don't
remember exactly what it was but
there was some
context around that
room maybe it was like a growling
she was in the moonlight she
looked really nice in the moonlight
which is moonlight
werewolf yeah but there was
something else too where it's like in
the room before you
heard growling there was a cage or
something oh yeah
where it was like there was another
dog in the laboratory
but i don't know if
it was the same also
it doesn't make sense that she's in the
moonlight so that's
when they turn into
werewolves that's
true yeah that i just never mind that
but you know speaking
of interesting things
near the sphinx
there's there's a
puzzle much later in
the game towards the end of the game
where there's these three levers and
this is the most escape room vibe i
got through the
whole game there
are these three levers and in the
sphinx room there
is a on the stairs
there are just like
images of lines like
all facing up and
then two facing up
and one facing down
and then like one
facing up two facing
down which is kind of like illustrating
like the steps of
which when you
should which levers you should pull down
in which order oh
and you might not
make that connection right away because
there's really no connection to like
what does this room have to do with that
lever room except for
the fact that there are these weird lines
on the stairs so like
if you're really oh
i see this game for a
long time yeah if
you're really playing this game for a long time like that would
be something that i feel like you would
you would you would probably put in your
back pocket like what does this mean and
then when you're at the levers i don't
know how long it might take you because
admittedly i did look
that one up and then i hated myself for it
because i felt like it
would have been so cool to have figured that
out through the the
symbols on there and
i had noted the
symbols like i said i
was kind of rushing just because i wanted
to finish it this week
but um but like
that's a cool one to
me i know that that
would be one that a
lot of people would probably get really
frustrated with and i
probably would too but
it's like it's really
difficult but i don't
think it's like crazy
unfair because of how
like just because of
how unorthodox those
symbols on the wall are
that should and by now
like you're that's
that's far enough into
the game that you not
only know the mechanics
but you also sort of
just get the gist of
what they want you to
do and by now you
should know that
there's gonna be some
unrelated stuff that
comes into play later
um so if you play
long enough you'll
probably make the connection yeah and
this could be specific
to me but i do feel
like sometimes the
difference between visual cues within a
room and text-based
cues even through
narrative storytelling
in this game uh
really make the
difficulty of the
puzzle uh you know
like wildly different
so i'll use the throne
room as an example
with that giant skeleton when you
first enter that room
it just tells you that
you've entered the
throne room with a
giant skeleton wearing
a golden crown
obviously like somebody
who made it this far
shouldn't try to take
the gold crown of the
skeleton but instead
you would notice that
he has one thing in
one arm and nothing in
the other and so the
game wants you to put
the hopefully this isn't
a spoiler alert i've
they want you to put
the scepter into his
other hand and then
that opens up like a
side of the wall that
then the game uses the
narrative to tell you
uh you know the wall
has opened and reveals a
ring-shaped hole and
it's like we're how
far into this game
now and you're
telling me like the
shape of the hole of
what would fit in it and i just literally
the thing i have right
exactly i just happen to have a ring in my
inventory like i don't
know like that's the kind of thing where
like yeah visually it
would be hard to make
it i guess ring shaped
and not be silly right
like not be a comical
like ring sketched onto
a wall but yeah
sometimes the text clues
are just easier right
and again i know we're
not trying to like
redesign the game here
but if they just did
close-ups for stuff like
that there i think there
are some other situations
where it would warrant it
instead of just defaulting
to descriptions but i and
and i'm sure in later
shadowgate games um it
does do that then it
would just be like oh
here's what it looks like
and then you just see a
circle carved into it um
like at scale and it
wouldn't be as on the
nose but it would still
be pretty easy you know
like like oh i've had
this ring for a long
time yeah i can see that
being for sure i'll i'll
admit when i got to that
point i actually didn't
have the ring yet so as
easy as the puzzle was
that i need a ring there i was like well where the
heck do i get this ring so i had to go back and
like re-explore the whole
castle so it was still uh
you know it's still a
challenge on my end
on the sequels and
spinoff side the original
ms dos game shadowgate
came out only two years
prior in 1987 so that
means it must have been pretty successful to then
immediately like within
two years time get a
nes port a lot of times
with these computer games
you see you know it's
from 1983 1985 like uh
you know only two years
time feels like a lot of
that also just went into
porting the game over to
the nes for anybody who
wants to check out that version it's available uh
to be played for free on
archive.org
yeah so maybe sean you
know you see the
differences uh the color
palette is definitely
different in uh in that
version of shadowgate
it's black and white right
well i believe yeah that's
what i was gonna say i believe the first the very
first version of the game
is black and white but i
think this archive.org one
lets you play like a couple of different
computer versions and so
you could play like a
very pinkish toned uh maybe
that computer was only
capable of like red color
values but yeah a lot
everything's just kind of pink
or is it just like uh an
old game boy color uh
playing a game boy game
where you can change the
oh that could be what it
is right yeah yeah
yeah uh anyway that's an
option for people and then
shadowgate kind of went
like m.i.a.
for a while until 1993 for the
turbo graphic 16 it's called
beyond shadowgate and
unlike the first shadowgate
this one is not a point
and click adventure it is a
platform game not in yeah
not an action game though uh
like a it's a classical
point and click style
adventure game viewed from
a platform perspective you
can move your hero around
examine manipulate and take
objects uh if you have a
moment look up beyond
shadowgate to just kind of
get the idea of what i'm
talking about i'm i'm
confused so there's you're
like clicking on things
still and yeah examining
things so isn't that just
the point and click game or
are you actually using
directional buttons and a
jump command to to
platform well that's a good
question sean i didn't play
the game so i can't say
this just looks like a
point and click adventure
game mike are you sure
though because i'm thinking
like in a point and click
adventure game with your
your character on screen and
you click on things and
then he goes to them right
and like interacts with
them yeah yeah i can't say
for certain that that's
what the turbo graphic 16
version does okay and then
in 1999 uh six years later
uh 12 years after the
original release we get the
game boy color version of
shadowgate so i know
everybody's dying to take
shadowgate on the go and
the game boy color version
with uh enhanced sprites and
animation um finally came
out and in certain regions was
released as shadowgate classic
but um i i think shadowgate
also is just fine as a title
do we have any preference
does it have to have the
classic thing is that just
like my is that marketing
i'd prefer uh new shadowgate
right because it's really not
though right like even shadowgate classic it's like
well there's only two games
released and nobody really
knows about beyond shadowgate
so yeah i think you need to
have a lot more games in your
lineup before you can start
being like and shadowgate it's just shadowgate that's
what that's what shadowgate was
you made the same game
it's shadowgate again
maybe just make it crystal
shadowgate yeah yeah
shadowgate gold and silver
but maybe they named it
shadowgate classic because
that same year in uh 1999
shadowgate 64 trials of the
four towers was released and
sean again not a game i have
played but this one looks like
a 3d first person adventure
game no pointing and clicking
uh even though that probably
would have been a better game on the n64 can you tell
me that that title one more
time shadowgate 64 trials of
the four towers and granted
like if you uh see a book or a
uh a flute you you can you get a
text interface that says will you
take the magical instrument and
you can select yes or no but that
doesn't make it a point and
click no no this one looks very
different having not played it it
almost looks like a fixed camera
perspective like like almost like a
survival horror game in a way but i
don't know um that's interesting and
in 2014 and still to this day they're
releasing uh this version of the
game shadowgate was remastered for
uh steam all the current consoles at
that time now it's available on
nintendo switch um it's basically the
same game as the original shadowgate
that we played today but with really
really nice artwork and uh quality of
life improvements i kind of am
interested in this like uh after
having played uh this version just to
see what are the quality of life
improvements and how did they did they
fix the game at all like in any
particular ways or is it really just
like a lot more moody i see a radial
like menu that probably makes it a bit
more easy to interact with things yeah
and even just you know what i'm saying
though right like if you look yeah yeah
steam page like just even the design of
it like the fact that every single room
has been uh redesigned i wonder if they
um you know made the hints a little more
suggestive in inside the room yeah i'm
i'm definitely interested in in playing
any other versions of this game and
seeing what it did but i feel like this
is not a game you can replay pretty
close to when you first played probably
like i need to wait until i forget
everything and then i'd love to replay
it someday so you're gonna move on to
beyond shadowgate that in that yes and
i'll let you know what it is i think
what i was trying to say there sean with
beyond shadowgate is that in that game
it's a different kind of point and click
where it's more like you're you're
watching your character like and you're
solving puzzles with him inside of the
room rather than like the first person
like just i don't know yeah i guess it
doesn't sound that different but to me
it seems like it's a different kind of
thing where like you're having your
character move about the room rather
than the static position of just like i'm
gonna place the sword here and i'm gonna
uh take this book like in this one you
kind of have looks like make your
character move around yeah to me like
just looking at screenshots uh it just
looks like a monkey island kind of thing
where you're you might be clicking around
and you click and he walks over there um
just that that classic style look but
maybe maybe it does control differently
no i think you're right though i think
that's what i'm saying is i misspoke
about my first line where i was like
this is a platform game not a point and
click game i'm just saying it's a
different kind of point and click game
similar it's more like monkey island and
less like shadowgate i would say that
those are two different kinds of games
oh yeah i mean like maybe subgenre yeah
yeah yeah exactly and that and this one
probably because it comes after uh
secret of monkey island it's like yeah
we're gonna do more like that because
that was a really uh that made money
selling game yeah it made a lot of money
and i'd like to make some money
i'd like some money mike i would love
some money and you know we're not gonna
get it right now because we have something
bigger to do sean wondering how you were
gonna do that segue right uh some people
think that they can bribe us with money
to get games like shadowgate on the
essential games list but in truth we
just vote on the segment which is called
the name that i already said it was which
is the essential games list
sean your vote i um i'm in a bit of a
pickle here because i do really like
shadowgate and i i i do think it it uses
the uh the abilities and the limitations
of the nes really well um i think that
for a uh an 8-bit escape the room slash
point-and-click adventure style game um
this works really well and the the puzzles
are great and the um some of the puzzles
are great and the art looks cool if a
little simplistic um but it's it's such a
good port apparently that it's basically
the same as every other release of this
game and i can only imagine that some of
the other releases are better than this
game in terms of like visual fidelity and
maybe uh ease of use i don't know um so i i
don't really know what to do in this
situation um as maybe i can just do this
as like a tentative a tentative yes a
tentative essential i'm gonna i'm gonna do
that and you can tell me if that's legal
or not well i mean we only have a few
episodes before where you'll have a
chance to take it off so i mean i feel
like i've done that before where i'm like
i'm gonna put this on and then maybe i'll
decide to take it off later but remember
yeah we all have to agree to take it
on that's true that's true i'm going to
tentatively say that this is an essential
game i'm going to jump in instead of
having uh joe vote next but i totally
agree with the gamifying the essential
games let's just have the fun right so
go ahead and put it on and see if that
strategy pays off um you know just going
to two things that you said about using the
power of the nes or just even the
experience of playing on the nes yeah i
think this game does it a lot better than
not essential game tetris did where like
people wanted nes tetris to be on the
essential games list probably most just
because that's the one that they played
a lot and it was crazy popular and it kind
of shook up the states at the time as
like you know everybody's playing nes
tetris like that specific version was
the one that put tetris on the map but
it really didn't like use the full power
of the nes or even just feel like an
nes game that could have been on any
console and you'll all know it but like
shadowgate is also on every console and
so to answer the other part for sean you
know knowing that this is a point and
click game i gotta think that just the
quality of life improvement of having a
mouse on a computer and being able to
freely move around between the the actual
room that you're in the mini map the
items uh in your inventory all that
stuff plus a keyboard is gonna go way
better than what the nes version laid out
here and for that reason alone um there
was one thing that i didn't quite talk or
none of us talked about really was the
cursor for the uh for the like the in the
room section where all of a sudden it
gives you like your mouse clicker in the
room there is an annoying thing on the
sides specifically on the right side of
the room where if you're kind of like
just hugging that edge for whatever
reason i'm not saying you have to be
but if you are trying to click on
something whether it would work or not
there's a chance that you might
accidentally just push a little further
than you might think and even though it
doesn't look like you're on the edge of
the screen you will now move back over
to the inventory and then you'll have to
come out of the inventory back to the
room and you won't start on the edge
you'll start back in the center and just
little things like that make me think
that like with a mouse this game is
superior and for that reason i'm going
to say that shadowgate is more of a play
it for nes people because it's more for
fans of the nes than for like everyone
must play the nes version of shadowgate
and that's where i stand and i just want
to jump in real quick before joe talks
again i'm sorry to interrupt you uh for
the second time um but i just want to
counter that i think that that was a
very elegant solution to having to like
use another input to like switch between
your inventory to the the action menu to
the uh the actual view of the room you're
in that that it was just directional it
felt very intuitive and yeah at the edge
it may think you're trying to move over to
your inventory but in any other that was
rare enough for me that it i just i
appreciated that ease of use in the user
interface so i that that's just my little
thing joe your vote well i'll start with
um the fact that i this is this game was
made for me like this is a game that like
i feel like if if i grew up if i played
this game growing up i would have absolutely
like fallen in love with it because it's
just what i'm always talking about i mean
this one really just has the essence of
an adventure and it's and it's one that
you you know it's not just an adventure
because you're in a castle but it's
because like the it's it's very immersive
and it gives you this like feeling of
progression in a way that we're not used
to on the nes because it's not this
action-based game um i had a i mean i had a
blast with this game i really did um as
far as what what what you guys are talking
about with like the user interface and like
the you know some things that were maybe not
like perfectly user-friendly like the like
the arrow um or like the the benefits of
using a keyboard i feel like that stuff was
so what is definitely there you're not wrong
at all but like it was so minimal to my
experience where it's like pretty quickly
got used to that and like yes it would have
been nice to have a mouse but it didn't
really bother me to to use the arrows to
move the mouse around because it was never
like it was never janky minus the the point
you brought up mike but but i agree with
sean it really never bothered me because it
happened like once or twice to me but um
yeah there are a couple things like that
that could be better there are a couple
times where you know the hints could be a
little less straightforward and overall i guess
i'll try and sum this up a little bit i i know
that what i love about this game is just a lot
of elements that are just inherent to most point
and click adventure games so like not even just
talking about other shadow gate versions i know
that there are like tons of other point and
click adventure games that are probably as good or
much better than this game and that was kind
of starting when i was playing it making me think
like well you know should i vote this is not so i
really want to because i really really like it but
then i kind of thought to myself like no just
because we've kind of had this debate before but
just because i know there are better point and
click adventure games doesn't mean that this
wasn't like a fantastic point and click adventure
game and like i had such a good time with it
friends of mine that i played with that don't
play all these nes games like we do we're having a
great time with it uh i'm going to put it on the
essential games list and never take it off on the
when when you try and vote it off sean so
sorry but but i'm going to put it on the
essential games list for now and everyone every
episode has a chance for an essential game and
that's not to discount short order and explode
which come out next week uh two power pad games
we're going to give them the same shot i don't
know if the power pad was ever released on the
commodore 64 but that's not going to disqualify
it either uh we're going to give this those two
games it's two and one wow uh we're going to
give them a fair shakeout along with all the
other games that we play except for the ones
on nostalgia bites that's our patreon.com
slash nostalgia only episodes where we look at
the famicom library those are not eligible for
the essential games list but they're pretty cool
games uh we teased a lot today about the
portopia serial murder case and i do think
anybody who enjoyed shadowgate would enjoy
playing that game as well but that's not the
next episode of uh nostalgia bites the next
episode of nostalgia bites is bocosuka wars and
you know just the idea of what that title could mean
should excite some people you just love to say it you
just love to say bocosuka wars see it rolls right
off the tongue like that um lots of other games
coming up just a little tease of things that are
coming up if you're not like on the discord or
checking these things out on the reg if you want
to play along we also have silent service that's a
sid meyer game uh the uncanny x-men it's based on a
comic book if you haven't heard of them uh willow
what's willow based off of is willow a movie
yeah i think it's a george lucas movie yeah i think that
sounds right i thought it was an m night
shamalan movie oh that's the village yeah now i'm
looking at willow and i can't tell but i thought it
was a quentin tarantino right oh wait no no that's
reservoir yeah yeah but important thing about willow
it's also the last game of 1989 and that goes into our best
of 1989 where uh we'll probably just add the remaining
249 games that we played so far onto the essential games
list yeah wow film